when you're young and hanging out with
your friends you will always ask the
question if they were to do a movie of
your life who's gonna play you it's cool
right yeah yeah how would he do great
yeah yeah I thought he did great it's
you know he doesn't really look like me
wait better-looking so that was scary I
was like what I think and I hit him in
the face of the bat and then what do you
think would play me in a movie about me
me when when you are whether you're an
actor or you went through what you went
through people sometimes put the role
model label on you and tell you that
you're their hero how do you still today
with what you went through and how do
you as an actor deal with that on days
when you don't feel that way what do you
think people are view that at me hero I
just like play part what somebody looks
you and they go I you are the role model
you are the thing that I strive to
achieve yeah on days when you don't feel
like that I just notice that signing all
those autographs oh my god yes it's
interesting everyone's watching it
you're signing autographs everyone's
like screaming at you girls everywhere
Rover 3500 people like jumping on our
golf cart yeah for me it's like I said
before it's it's heroes and my eyes or
our first responders let's save my life
and you know the medical staff the
people that you know they show up and
they go to work every day and do hard
jobs see that stuff at the hospital and
and you know people that go the physical
therapists at work of rehab and the
nurses nurses are huge thing I I saw my
doctors like once or twice and it was
all nurses so nurses are my personal
here I think and I think also just shows
the power of stories you know
storytelling I've spent my life and you
know my career's about telling stories
and when a story is really strikes you
and really moves you you know and I
happen to be in movies where you know
stories strike remove people I think it
in the end you're part of that feeling
with them you know there's intimacy so I
think that you you you share with a lot
a large group of people maybe you'll
never even meet and as a result I think
they have there's an intimacy with you
and like when you know you go out
somewhere where at the premiere and
they're signing autographs because of
that it's because of the power of us was
this hard like was this hard - at the
end of the day doing this playing
playing that part doing everything that
you had to go through just emotionally
you know yeah there were times I think
in their situations in this film that
you know we'll never get close to what
Jeff actually went through but I think
even just conjuring that up and being in
that space and all the things that we
discussed but all the things that
tatianna and I played in those moments
together in particular very emotional
times you know but always because Jeff's
always like this like always a sense of
humor in the midst of all of it you know
some of those scenes are harrowing but
also there's always a joke here and
there throughout the film and throughout
those scenes so I don't ever use the
word hard when I talk about making a
movie you know in the movie you famously
turned down meeting Oprah have you met
Oprah yet no I have no you have no I
would love to meet her she seems like a
wonderful person it's just at that point
of time of my life it was just like
what's going mom like my mom and my aunt
you were trying to do all this stuff for
me that I didn't really want yeah and I
want to get your take on this and then
your take on this when you read
headlines today after the movie screen
last night they're calling it an
oscar-worthy performance does that
matter to you and does that matter to
you does that matter to you yeah look I
love I want you don't work
I'm Miranda John Poole oh no David West
read all like the real yeah
worked really hard on the Sun Carol's
like the other people I think that
because from my standpoint to see this
and to it hits home to me personally
maybe I didn't think it was gonna be
like this touching and I wasn't gonna
cry ah it's gonna be like go through it
and go through the motions put it makes
me cry makes me laugh it's quick it's
crazy
you guys are dudes for life now yeah
yeah you know what I'd say is I think
knowing him and seeing him is you know
to understand who he is and understand
his story is what I last night and the
response to the movie has been
incredible and as a result of really
it's him you know and I said this before
and I felt this I said the most nervous
that I was and I would be in
anticipation of showing that movie last
night was was your feelings and your
response to it because there's no one
like him and he's all I've thought about
for the past you know two years while
we've been making this movie and he's
been on my mind almost every day through
your pre-production put a lot into it
those you know you know you worked hard
I saw that you know to see that it's a
lot of respect and towards me it's a lot
of respect it's you know he could have
breeze through it down the whole movie
and you know eighty eight months and
then gone and on to the next one but put
a lot of time everybody put a lot of
time and every time it means a lot to me
and really thank you guys